[Music]
we are in the middle of nowhere
Hillsboro North Carolina this behind me
is my house
which just so happens to be a life-sized
replica of Michael Myers house from John
Carpenter's classic horror film
Halloween this great big story is made
possible by Geico happy Geico ween 50
minutes could save you 15% or more on
car insurance
[Music]
my name is Kenny Caperton I've been a
horror fan my entire life and I always
take my passions a little bit too far
Halloween was this little movie when it
came out in 1978 and became one of the
biggest horror movies of all time it's
one of the movies that started it all it
created the slasher genre as it is so
Michael Myers he is the boogeyman he's
kind of your classic monster like
Frankenstein or Dracula or the Wolfman
and he's just a guy with the white mask
and goes around and kills people in
Halloween night I've probably seen
Halloween at least a hundred times if
not more than I just got this crazy idea
what would it be like to live in the
Michael Myers house building this house
was not easy at all I was 26 years old I
never owned a home or anything and it
was a lot of challenges doing it finding
blueprints and how am I gonna build a
house of I have no blueprints I talked
to everyone known to man a local library
tax office the city and we just couldn't
find blueprints so I called up one of
the people who was living in the
original house and they went out and
they measured the entire house for me
I watched the films over and over and
over again and I put all this
information together and that's really
how it started it's a beautiful house
it's a turn a century home it's perfect
in every way you can look at it
my house is completely filled from head
to toe with horror memorabilia and
different collectibles and film problems
it's a actual butcher knife signed by
Nick Cassell who played Michael Myers in
the original Halloween
I've been collecting this stuff since I
was a little kid I love movie posters I
love car artwork I have I would say
hundreds if not thousands of different
pieces of memorabilia in the house
[Music]
wouldn't it be cool if you could just
live in something everyday that you love
so much you had a passion for it's like
you know if you were a fan of a sports
team you could just build that stadium
and just live in it all day long you
know what I mean so that's the feeling I
get every time then I'm here I'm living
in my favorite movie every single day
I've lived in Myers house like there
it's an incredible feeling I've been
here over a decade I don't think I could
ever walk away from this home I really
don't I mean it's funny but I have
reoccurring nightmares that I don't live
in this house like I'll pull down the
driveway and it's not there I just don't
think I could ever walk away from this
house I love it too much it means too
much to me
[Music]